i turn my camera on I could my fingers
on way so yes today I'm going to share
to you a bit of experience about Gaines
aye lad that I'm not exactly an awesome
game developer I've made to gains one
which is very stupid and simple and the
other which I'm talking about is
hopefully bit better so firstly the
slides are going to be up on speaker
deck after the end of this talk so
they're not there yet but they will be
so a bit of an introduction about myself
I am as mentioned from australia sydney
where we're probably known for our opera
house and our beer and I work out
atlassian where there's beer on tap
except I don't drink so I've been at
last year for the past five nearly six
years and I worked on various projects
and products in particular booked on
confluence some of you may have heard of
that now as a developer I think how jobs
are very creative and therefore I like
to create things and I think many of us
do here as well but I don't like to
create just computer programs and apps
in fact I like to sometimes venture away
from the computer and create things that
are a bit more tangible like soft toys
but I find in the end I gravitate back
towards the laptop sitting in my room
coding away at some random idea I have
so now that you know a bit about me let
us continue on our journey so before we
start on the journey let us start by
doing a quick survey with some audience
participation so put your hand up if
you've wanted to make a game or have an
idea for a game come on yep so quite a
few now keep your hand up if you started
on this idea
bit more and keep your hand up if you've
actually finished this idea and it's
published so that people who you do not
know can download and play this game
because I think we've got two people so
as you can see there's a bit of a
pattern here and that is as developers
we like creating things and gains is one
of these things and I think the reason
for this is games is one of the rare
things that we can create that our
friends and family understand it might
be quite hard to explain to your friend
what a web torrent web RTC thing is they
might be like so I can stream videos
like youtube what's the difference but
with games you give it to them and
they'll be like oh cool I can play
flappy bird they understand exactly what
it's for without you trying to dumb it
down for them but the problem is there's
lots of ideas and we rare that they
rarely see the light of day and I think
this is a huge problem mainly because as
developers I think we're all very
talented and skilled and we have the
ability to create these games that we
have in our mind but life gets in the
way and we rarely finish these ideas and
they just sort of either stay half
completed on a computer or worse yet
they stay in our mind going nowhere and
that is why today I want you to I want
to I guess talk to you about my
experience in making my most recent game
trichrome on so try chroma is a simple
puzzle game where you slide the tiles
around you when you slide the tiles
around and you have three or more of the
same color that line up the tiles
disappear if you clear the board you
level up you get a new color it gets
hard up if the board feels up it's game
over start again as you can see it's a
very simple game it's completely written
in JavaScript HTML CSS and I use Cordova
to make it a native web app now I have
to give it a quick plug it is available
on the Google Play Store which is why
I'm standing here today not yet
available on iOS or Windows because I
didn't
time but I promise you it will be there
soon and I think trichrome I started as
many of you will have guessed with an
idea so the idea came from playing two
or four eight and three and also connect
four so one night after getting really
frustrated at 2048 because I can never
get that 2048 tile and so I thought what
have I change the rules slightly what if
instead of combining numbers i combined
colored tiles and like connect four when
enough of them are in a line something
magic happens and so this was an idea
and I went to sleep and unfortunately
many ideas and here right they stay in
your mind and you never get anywhere
with them they just sort of disappear
and collect us so the first step I think
that you need to do in order to get
somewhere is to do something with your
idea create a prototype have something
that you can play with in front of you
so with a prototype you want to spend as
little time as possible you want it to
be quick and hockey you don't want to
make the code look pretty you just want
something working so the prototype for
trachoma was a hacked up piece of
JavaScript done in a weekend and I can
promise you your code is going to be
horrible it's a prototype it should be
trachoma had global variables I had
hard-coded parameters there were bugs
but I could have fixed them because the
code was so fragile but that didn't
matter because a key thing for the
prototype is you want to validate two
things firstly you want to validate that
your idea works and secondly you want to
validate that it's technically possible
so in terms of idea you want to make
sure your idea actually has some legs as
harsh as it sounds many of our ideas are
actually pretty crap so you want to
create something quick and dirty that
you can prove that your idea actually
makes sense and on top of this once you
have something in front of you you can
give it to your friend or your flatmate
and they can play with it and tell you
if they think it makes sense
if they think it looks promising and if
it passes this test you know you've got
something that you can spend more time
with the second thing is validating if
it's technically possible now of course
in this day and age it's very rare to
have something that is technically
impossible right it's we can do almost
anything we want but the question is
more so can you finish this project by
yourself or maybe with a friend as
you'll notice try chroma is very very
simple it is very basically no graphics
in fact it's just a bunch of colored
rectangles and that is because I can't
draw to save my life I wanted to write a
game in which I can play to my strengths
one of which which is not drawing in
fact even the colors I had to get a
friend to select the colors for me
because apparently my choices were
horrible so now that you've validated
your idea is promising and you feel that
you can technically make this possible
you're on to your real adventure and
that is creating the real thing now when
you're making the real thing two things
to keep in mind firstly you want to
throw away or your prototype code it is
horrible code that you do not want to
build on top of because you want to
start with a fresh slate with no
technical debt it may seem like a great
idea because you have something already
working but trust me in the long run
you're going to hate yourself for it the
real purpose of your prototype was to
get a better understanding of your game
idea and not to give you code to start
with the second thing with when you're
creating your real thing to keep in mind
is you want to build a Minimum Viable
Product you don't want to build
something that has all the bells and
whistles you want to have something that
is just enough so that you can have it
up there published which means something
that is just enough that is functional
reliable usable and has elements of
design and thought put into it when
you're building your MVP keep in mind
this is not what you want to do you
don't want to build the tiny bits and
pieces and eventually just try and piece
everything together because I go
NTU some pieces will not work and things
are fall apart and you'll be in hell
instead you want to do something that
looks more like this you want to build
bits and pieces in such an iteration so
that you can test along the way the
first iteration might be something
really simple for example the tiles will
move and you can check for combinations
but there's no detection for leveling up
or game over the second iteration you
might actually check for game over third
iteration you check for level up and you
add that new tile color fourth iteration
you add score to it as you can see can
slowly build up your game so that along
each stage of the way you can do this
very important thing called play testing
now play testing is something I highly
recommend you do as often as possible
and as early as possible the main reason
for this is as a developer you're going
to know your game inside out and you're
going to have a lot of assumptions and
play testing or challenge these
assumptions as frustrating as it is to
watch your friend sort of struggle
playing your game and missing the most
simplest and easiest rule it or all that
means is you've made the incorrect
assumption that people understand how
your game works at the start of your
play testing you'll notice that you need
to make some rule changes some things
won't work or you'll get some feedback
which will enhance your game a lot if
you just tweak a rule a bit and towards
the end you'll find out what confuses
your users you'll realize that if you
add in a tutorial it'll make it so much
easier or if you change the way the
scoring system works users will be able
to understand what it is so now on to
actually developing the game when you're
developing the game I highly suggest you
do two things firstly do something such
that you are learning something that
you'll find interesting and secondly
make a development process as painless
as possible so the reason I say you
should do something in which you're
learning is because at some point in
time no matter how excited you are about
your
current idea you're going to get bored
of it two weeks or two months down the
track you're going to have to implement
something that is extremely boring and
if you're not learning anything along
this development process you're going to
just put it away and it's going to be
shelved and it will disappear in terms
of making on develop process less
painless I think that is quite simple
you want to reduce as much friction as
possible because you want to make it as
easy as possible to develop your game
there's already enough things going on
in the world and in your life to make it
harder for yourself which is something
you don't want to do and as this slide
may have suggests you may have guessed
my suggestion for learning something and
making it easier in my case was using
TDD or test-driven development so if you
haven't heard of test-driven test-driven
development the idea is quite simple
instead of writing production code first
you have to stop and you don't write any
production code because the first thing
you want to do is to write a test you
want to write a simple test to test a
tiny bit of functionality for example in
track promo the scoring system I wrote a
test that said there's a combination of
size length 3 on the first level you got
to give the user five points now I wrote
this test and obviously it failed
because I had nothing that gave me score
so the second thing I did was write a
bit of code to make this test pass and
you want to write the minimum amount of
code to write this test to make this
test pass and that meant writing a
function that returned five you're
probably thinking that's a stupid
function it's not going to work but am
ed test pass and that's the idea of
test-driven development write a small
test and the minimum amount of code to
make that test pass and then now the
important part is you repeat this
process I'll write another test this
time if you have a combination of size
for you return ten points and of course
my damn implementation will have all
failed this test so go back and i right
improved implementation a bit so it
passes both tests
now you keep doing this refract this
loop and soon you will need to refactor
your code and this is why test-driven
development is often known as red green
refactor and after a while you'll notice
you'll have clean code that is also
functionally correct now this is great
on a lot of levels mainly because
test-driven development encourages good
coding practice and good code in general
the test forces you to think about the
code before you start writing which will
mean you'll have better code less bugs
and more and just better code in general
and also the tests themselves were
ensure that you don't fall prey to
regression if any early test if you
break anything the tests will go red and
you know you'll have to fix something up
so this is great with game development
because games have a lot of change in
them and if you have a suite of tests
that will help back you up you have
confidence in continuing to write your
code and you won't sort of be wary to
change your code and you'll be able to
code more easily again making your
development process easier the other
great thing about games and test driven
development which may seem like an
uncommon pair is they actually fit very
well together so the reason for this is
games have rules rules are
specifications and tet specifications
lend themselves extremely well to tests
in fact if you think of the jasmine
testing framework it gets you to write
specifications and not tests so as an
example try Kromah has a simple rule if
the grid is full then it's game over and
as you can see this translates pretty
much exactly to as jasmine test you
described that the grid should know when
it's full because this means you need to
do something about the game over state
another example you should grid should
know when it's empty because this time
you need to do something about leveling
up now you don't have to just restrict
yourself to asserting the rules of the
game you can also assert things like the
behavior of the game for example the
grid should not allow you to add at all
to us
this space that already has a tower it
should give you a huge warning because
if that happens something has gone wrong
so by the end of the TDD process you'll
have a suite of tests that lets gives
you confidence that your game engine is
behaving the way you intended to and as
I alluded to earlier this is extremely
important because your game is
definitely going to change all the play
testing that you are doing at the start
of your game you'll notice that you need
to make rule rule changes you need to
tweak the way that your games works so
that your system works in a nice balance
and this means refactoring your code now
without the suite of tests refactoring
will be a daunting task because you're
not sure what you will break and not
show of your introduced regression bugs
and this creates friction and obstacle
to working on your game but with this
suite of tests you will know that you
can actually dive in change the code and
as long as your test stayed green you
still have a working game if they may be
bugs in it but at least it is exactly
the same as you've left it before your
refactor the other benefit is this bead
back loop that you get from test-driven
development so especially at the start
of your game when you don't have any UI
and the only thing you have is the game
engine and the logic this feedback loop
is is incredibly invaluable do not
underestimate the power of the red green
refactor loop when you're developing it
sort of like this incentive that helps
you murder motive helps motivate you to
keep going and this brings me to a small
confession and that is i only tested the
game engine logic i did not test the UI
in fact i have zero tests for the UI
code and this is because i think UI
testing is extremely hard and as i
mentioned earlier you want to reduce
friction and there is a line between
setting up a lot of boilerplate code to
get your future development easy and
spending going down a rabbit hole and
try
get something working so as annoying as
it is to have to manually test you I I
think it was the right choice because if
I did go and try to set up all the crazy
you I staff one I would not be confident
that tests everything and two I'm would
still probably be there trying to get it
to setup and test everything so
therefore to test you I I simply worked
in what I was most familiar with the
chrome devtools now this is great
because I had access to all the tools I
was used to the Dom inspector
console.log the script tag to add break
points etc I was able to develop very
quickly as you will notice I've been
able to device mode on chrome developer
tools and that is because my main aim
for try chroma was to make it a mobile
web app a mobile app sorry I could have
made it a web app by adding in media
queries but I wanted it to be
installable and available for on the
Play Store and for this I needed to have
some magic I wanted it to be as simple
as possible to translate the JavaScript
that I'd written into a native
installable application and for this the
magic came in the form of Apache Cordova
so if you haven't heard of Apache
Cordova it is effectively a platform for
building native web applications using
javascript HTML and CSS so Apache
Cordova provides you with a set of AP is
that allows you to access the native
functionality from JavaScript and the
great thing was Cordova was extremely
easy to use do you simply create a
Cordova project by running the Cordova
create command and it will create a file
structure that looks something like this
our Cordova provides support to many
many platforms including Android iOS
Windows blackberry and I don't believe
Firefox OS as well but for the rest of
this talk I'm going to mainly
concentrate on the Android platform
because i only own an Android device so
I couldn't really test on the other
at forms but all the other platforms are
pretty much the same for example to add
the Android platform you run this
command you've got to run the iOS
platform you change android/ios when you
do run this command what Cordova does is
it modifies this directory structure
that you've got here and adds in the
Android directory under your platforms
and if you open the Android directory
you'll see all the familiar Android
application folders folders and files
that you would see in a native android
game or app so you have the
androidmanifest.xml you've got the
assets for your images libs resources
and resources directory for your java
classes but because we're writing a
Cordova app in JavaScript HTML CSS
you're actually not going to touch any
of this in fact in order to modify the
behavior of your application you're
generally going to be modifying the
config.xml file so the config.xml file
looks something like this looks a bit
scary because it's all just XML but it's
actually really simple and really
powerful so for example you want your
game to run in full screen you just set
the preference or full screen to true or
you maybe you want the game to run
always important so when the user flips
the mobile device it won't change the
orientation yet another line so Cordova
will translate these directly to the
native code for you you can also specify
the application name and this is what
appears under the icon that is on the
home screen and of course you can
specify the application icon itself so
as you can see the confidant XML in
Cordova is extremely powerful it makes
it a life easier when you want to
translate your web app game into the
native game into a native app and of
course this is just the behavior if you
want to add functionality you can use
the Cordova plugins now the Cordova
plugins allowed to access native
functionality like the camera or in-app
purchases gps accelerometer etc allowing
you to make a very powerful game or
application the great news
is most of these plugins are open source
which means if it doesn't do quite what
you want you can contribute back to
their plug-in and enhance it or if a
plugin does not exist you're free to
create your own using Cordova plugins
are almost just as easy as creating
Cordova project itself simply find the
plug-in key you want you add the plug-in
and then you can start using it now
since I wanted to create it as a native
app obviously I needed to create and
build the install APK file and again
Cordova makes it really easy by just
running the court over build command and
to run it on your device as expected
Cordova run so what this does is Cordova
has basically meant that with very
minimal amount of work i can go from the
Chrome browser into a mobile phone now
it is probably at this moment that
you'll notice the app on your mobile
will not look like the app on your
Chrome browser because the browsers on
your phone and on a device are
completely different and as we as front
end is all no different browsers mean
different CSS quirks and possibly
different JavaScript quirks so right now
you probably want to right click on your
phone to try and change something and to
inspect the element but unfortunately
you can't right click on your phone
which means you can't debug but the good
news is you can do remote debugging and
it is extremely easy all you need to do
is connect your phone to your laptop
fire up your app and then fire up chrome
on your laptop and go to the Chrome
inspect tab and then select the app as
the window you want to debug and you'll
see something like this as you can see
there's the chrome web tools inside on
your laptop and as you hover over the
diamond elements it will hover over the
corresponding elements on your phone
itself now this is really cool because
you can do everything you're used to you
can modify delete add Dom elements and
they will be reflected on your phone
I you can change the CSS as well set
breakpoints look at console.log
basically everything you're used to and
this is an invaluable tool when you're
debugging and making sure that your app
looks correct on the phone so this
brings me to the very key point and that
is you definitely want to do device
testing you want to remember to test on
a variety of devices in particular for
Android because there are different
screen sizes different performance
different performance levels on each on
each phone and this is because Cordova
uses the webview so you want to make
sure that despite the differences
between your operating systems and your
browser's it will look that and behave
the same and one more thing and that is
when you're swiping on the phone it is
actually very different to using a key
to using the keyboard on your computer
so you definitely want to do device
testing it's almost as important as play
testing so there's one small gotcha that
I have to mention and that is with the
Cordova docks so the Cordova docks are
pretty good they're a bit of a hit and
miss at times but in general they get
you to where you want the gotcha is you
want to make sure you're looking at the
right version of the docks so I was
using Cordova 3.6 and every so often I
would Google a problem that I had click
on the first link that google gave me
and be completely confused and that was
because i was looking at an older
version of the Cordova doc so it'll be
confusing because it's talking about the
right thing but in a different way so
when you're using these docs make sure
you're using the right version and can
see that in the top right drop down this
will save you hours and hours of
confusion now as with all things we know
that development process is not all fun
and games you're going to have problems
and obstacles along the way you have
technical problems that you need to
solve and life may also get in hilly way
so in regards to technical problems I
definitely hit one as I was developing
trichrome on to the first and I guess
the biggest one that I hit was this
seeing here if you look at this you may
think that it's great index CSS image
JavaScript I can just open this this
should be a web app and you can develop
on your browser unfortunately this is
not the case and this is because if you
try and open the index.html here you're
going to get a javascript error it's
going to say something along the lines
of Cordova is not found and this is
because Cordoba jayus is a platform
specific file and it is generated by the
Cordoba build command and placed into
the platforms directory and its really
only accessible when you load it on your
phone that the index.html points to the
correct Cordova j/s file now of course
when you hit problems you don't just
give up you want to find a solution for
it so my solution was I wanted to still
develop in chrome because I'd wanted to
make my dev psychol as easy as possible
I did not want to deploy on to a phone
every time I wanted to test that would
be too much friction and I feel like I
would give up very quickly so my
solution was quite simple here is your
Cordova app and I wanted to not work in
the cord / app and work in the web
browser so effectively ignore the cord /
app create and put it under sort of a
top level directory and create my web
app files that I've used to index CSS
image and JavaScript outside of the
Cordova wrap so now I basically just
modify and edit using these three four
sorry these four directories and files
and I could open this in chrome and
develop as I'm used to and the trick
here is when I wanted to test them a
device I would copy and paste those
files into the corner of our WWE now
this worked great the first time because
as developers I think we are all a bit
lazy and copying and pasting files into
directories isn't something that we want
to do time is already very precious
finding the few hours after work to
develop on your side project and hobby
and game is already hard so you don't
know waste these hours
copy and pasting files and it's also
very error-prone so this is where
automation comes in and in JavaScript
automation is effectively grant so grant
if you haven't heard of it is awesome
it's a JavaScript a strong arm and it
lets you specify a config file and then
once you've done the specification you
only need to run grunt and run a command
and it'll do this automatically for you
so I used grunts to automate this copy
pasting by specifying a few
configurations for my CSS and JavaScript
so for my CSS this is what my
configuration looks like i use the sass
plug-in created a Cordova task and
effectively as you can see in my main
dot FCSS on my top level CSS directory
when I got caught the grunt plugin to
compile the file I got it to compile it
into the main dot into main dot CSS but
under the Cordova directory effectively
copying it into the correct place where
I needed it and the great thing about
ground is it lets user so specify other
options such as I want the style to be
compressed to save space did a similar
thing to JavaScript using the uglify
plugin created a Cordova task and just
said anything under JavaScript or
library copy it into the Cordova classes
and bundled these both of these tasks
into one parent household pulled over so
now during my development process all I
needed to do was to run grunt cordova
and edward compile and minify my CSS and
my JavaScript and place it into the
Cordova directory ready for me to build
and run it on my device so this might
sound like a lot of things but the key
point here is you want to simplify a
development process as possible the
problems you meet might be different the
problems I've met but the key thing to
remember is you want to make it as easy
as possible for you so you don't have to
worry about all the peripheral things
what you want to worry about is creating
your game and making it work there's
frankly speaking there is not enough
in a day to remember boring things such
as commands and copy and pasting files
now as frustrating as it is for me I
have some good news for you and that is
if you're going to create a native web
app of Cordova you don't need to do
anything of what I just explained
because in Cordova for or they fix this
they fix this by adding the browser as a
platform so remember how I mentioned you
couldn't open the index.html because
Cordova jayus was a compiled version a
compiled file specific to the platform
well now the browser is at platform so
you can add it and when you want to do
any testing you can run it and then you
would have the browser as a platform
once more word of warning is that the
browser platform is still in the initial
stages so there are a few bugs but in
general I give it a quick run and it
looks like it works relatively well so
if you are at this stage of the
development where your periodically
testing on the phone and you're checking
and fixing up a few things it is time
for celebration because you've made it a
long way you've made it further than a
lot of people your idea has actually
grown some legs and it's getting
somewhere the problem though is the
finishing line and this is the hardest
part of all developing the game itself
is challenging you're going to face many
technical challenges but it is probably
equally challenging to make that last
twenty percent and cross the finishing
line so I'm going to give you five tips
many of which I have alluded to already
during this talk so the first thing is
make sure when you're developing you're
always learning something during the
development process because otherwise
you're going to get bored really quickly
and the game will disappear and be
shelved now keep in mind and I think
this is something as developers we make
a mistake very often and that is the
learning does not stop when the
development stops you can keep learning
even after developing so the act of
publishing your game is learning the act
of
getting your game out into the world is
learning getting feedback from some one
halfway across the world because they
don't understand English is learning so
if you want to learn stuff that's more
than just development publish your game
second tip is friends are amazing
they're great for being the first play
testers you can continuously nag them
for feedback they'll get annoyed but you
can still keep nagging them and of
course they're there to push to help you
and to encourage you there there as
moral support there's going to be times
and you just don't want to work on the
game and they'll be there to give you
that small nudge that you need to just
cross the finishing line on a more
technical level scope scope is something
that is a pitfall for many projects both
personal and I guess work-related scope
creep you've probably all heard about it
is horrible and this is a chance as the
owner of your own game or project to
limit the scope as much as you can
especially when you're playtesting and
you get all this awesome feedback you're
going to want to add and change things
but you want to be careful going to be
strict and remember to work on the
Minimum Viable Product you want to if it
doesn't add value to the game drop it
remember even after you've you released
your game you can still add things to it
you're creating a piece of software
you're not creating a building after
version 1 point 0 you can release
version 11 and it'll be okay people will
be happy with it and something to help
us cope is to set yourself a deadline
hard deadlines work best so for example
the deadline for trachoma was this talk
and this is why I'm standing here now
because I had to get it published but if
you don't have a hard deadline set
yourself a soft deadlines a deadline is
better than none so if you set yourself
a dot soft deadline make sure you get
your friends to hold yourself
accountable for it maybe set yourself a
punishment if you don't make yourself
deadline and finally last but not least
is to start just start on creating the
game start on the prototype get your
idea out of your head
it into the computer start on fixing
that bug that has been annoying you for
the past week start on adding that small
little feature that will enhance your
game a lot i find that starting is
almost just as hard as finishing if so
as clichéd as it may sound i think if
you start you're halfway there so
hopefully many of you who have had ideas
either started or still just in your
head will now be a bit more motivated to
go forth and complete start on your idea
and see it through to completion so just
one more thing this one final thing
isn't exactly critical to helping you
complete your game but I think it's
something that is extremely nice to have
and that is to give credit to the people
that actually help you make your game
possible so in this line I know they're
not here but I'd like to say thanks to
my great friends Deborah grace and LeAnn
because they were incredibly supportive
and they definitely played a role in
helping me finish the game trichrome arm
and also in terms of the slides I
grabbed art from these people who shared
their awesome artwork and icons and the
MVP image which was actually based off a
Spotify talk so that is the end of my
talk and I hope that you guys have now
been inspired and had the tools to start
on your game and finish it thank you
very much thank you thank you
and so we hope that next time when you
ask how many of you have done it more
hands will be raised thanks for sharing
your journey because when you do it very
recently and share it immediately have
so many things to reflect on a couple of
questions for Peggy especially those of
you who have been thinking about coding
a game and not been able to do so any
questions over there I run oh yes i did
i'd be interested to know if you had any
issues with performance on mobile using
just the responsiveness of the UI or
anything like that and how you dealt
with it okay um so for track promo i was
lucky in that it was a very simple game
there was there's no actual animation
except for when you slide the tiles
which is maybe like once every five
seconds i looked into it a bit and
initially I was using CSS animations
which I thought was more performant on
mobile if you enable the 3d sort of
translate but Indiana actually went with
velocity jas because despite using
jQuery it actually optimizes it and now
mobile browsers are actually quite
powerful to handle JavaScript animations
and velocity jas does give you more
flexibility with CSS yep all right it
and maybe just one more i'll get the mic
to you what's the feedback been like and
it has that affected the development of
the game going forward sir the feedback
so the game has only been released for
about two or three weeks and one of the
things that I still am learning to do is
how to market it better so I haven't
actually had a great deal of uptake on
it but in terms of feedback from
playtesting to improve the game during
my development process the first
iteration for the prototype was actually
quite different from
the final version and that was because
most of my friends said that they needed
a goal for the game and that is where I
basically changed the entire rules in
order to I guess improve the game i'm
hoping i won't received that type of
feedback from the general public because
i find that trachoma is already quite
well polished in a way it could be
biased that i think in general you just
have to take feedback as it comes great
Thank You Peggy thank you for your
journey and your sharing on it